for
so I think even in the patreon
group which is fine you're you are where
you are but of course here you are where
you
are and
um we're so used to in
[Music]
iido understanding the techniques are
like mechanical sequences I just learned
the sequence
and I'm going to be good to
go of course that's all ego tripartite
mind right and so we're so used to
working with it we just think it's
mechanical it's sequential I learn the
moves and I go
okay
um but I would say no behind everything
I'm doing is an
internal aspect by which without you
can't do what I'm doing you can't in a
way what what I'm doing
externally is like
a it it's a technology to develop what
I'm doing internally okay but because
you can't do what I'm doing externally
without doing what I'm doing
internally so for example we're doing
this technique and he comes around okay
and it looks okay I go down and then I
go up oh stop him you see and if you
start paying
attention uh the angle here don't
move is that an angle of incidence to
what he's doing so if you come around
camera go move where you can see it
okay and I'm basically on the top on the
front of his bone you feel that trist so
basically I'm just stopping that like
that you see that's a bracing angle
there
okay my Joe is not there my Joe is not
there my my Joe is
here you see
that okay so here's that bone where he
was where I was before do you see that
and now I'm here and this this will
stick I can stop and of course if I
could stop I could Project without it
slipping
off without it having to be here you see
and just blocking
okay so I have to know how to make an
inate object stick in order to do that I
have to know how to make my my touch
stick you
see okay and if I can't stick I can't do
the move I got to change the
move
okay also as we're coming
around when I go ahead and make that
stick I don't have to
stop okay I don't have to be on two
feet I don't have to have good
posture still stick
if on the other
hand I have to have a stopping angle
here I probably have to have a bracing
angle on my feet and I got to
stop get everything in place and then I
do a secondary move where I just push
him
away but if my move is internalized or
his I'm sorry his energy is internalized
and it's passing through me the same way
I don't need to have a good base you
can't push me over and likewise I can
project him without me falling I could
also move through that
energy so I don't have to
wait okay and I get some benefits from
that if he's doing the last
move that's a lot of weight he's already
Sol and he's got a bracing angle you see
he goes
back he has
stance and he's coming around and boom
is when I hit him do you see when that
foot's in flight and it's not so good as
opposed to Foot In Front back foot in
back and weight shifted forward
okay so I'm doing the move
and I go and I keep
moving you can see he never gets onto
the front foot and
then it's much easier even mechanically
to just stop him mid step with the foot
in the back okay he goes and you stop
mid step you understand it's much easier
and he
goes and he's here and he's weighted
with that back foot that's
it's not that I can't project him I can
but it's much harder if I can't project
him to get in so
likewise that that that's a skill that I
that I have as I'm going
here I can be on one
leg because this energy is not really
stopping
me well I'm moving towards
him let me exaggerating that part for
you there's the little
stick okay and then
likewise even if he was in that last
stance you see you kind still take this
energy that he has and internalize it
and you can project even on the back
foot it's
doable okay that just makes it more
easier when he's he's not based and I'm
still going to project so as I come
around easy peasy okay so let's look at
some of the internal things that I have
one is I had an
adhesion
here this requires more
movement okay two
I'm moving at him when he's moving at me
without losing the
adhesion so that when I
project I'm projecting
that okay because I don't get pinned as
I'm walking forward do you you guys
understand okay and so if you start
doing this technique
externally and
here
[Music]
and
you're going to go that can't be it cuz
I'm musling I'm Yong Ying okay well why
am i y
Ying because it's external that the Y
aspect of him is not passing through me
it's not being internalized
okay so let's try
this let's focus in on the problem of
waiting okay don't wait
so he goes and I'm not going to wait for
him I'm moving
in right
away so first you move your left
foot in and the right foot goes and I
don't care what angle incidence you do
on the hand you're just going to learn
to
walk underway left right okay that
that'll be our little bridge will use
from external to internal okay try
[Music]
[Applause]
it so here's another one it looks like
something
else and I just need to do the moves and
it's going to work but it doesn't it
doesn't work okay there's an interal
aspect and we can't do it so we take it
out and now the moves different from
what I did and the difference really is
between does it work or does it not work
okay so um you're going to have to
probably move around I'll show you what
I mean okay so
the opening is whatever cool here's
where we start working okay so when I
come in
boom okay that's your strike we know
that part all right here's where I do
something different so when I come
around
here I am going to take this leg
out this leg I'm going to go this way
and move
it do you guys got it and that means I
have to
ground so he has his
base and I have to ground the back foot
do you see it I'm going to
project through this leg this
way what we usually
do is we don't and we just
accelerate
yeah I I have
a a sweep
here pop this
way so if you don't mind leave your Jo
there you stand
up and we know there's a projection
Force here
okay you're going to come over
here and you're going
to do that do you understand just start
with some
pressure okay and then we know the
Joe right is pulling this down so I
going like that do you see and there's
your front
osition so we go back let's not have
that
F okay and this this Joe's pull on here
that leg's going around the
hip so now start looking for that he he
feels
it right
here you should be able to see how he's
not Landing under me let me do the other
acceleration roll
right it's here just there a roll
[Music]
there look how different his body has to
look see how horizontal he gets in space
okay most you will bite it they're not
used to being that made that open okay
but but that's what makes it different
that's a true fall okay he either lets
go of the weapon or he holds on to it
and get thrown
okay last detail on this
version this hand don't come
up follow the
inance go slow so you see what I'm doing
you see I'm there and I come
up
smooth things out too don't
zigzag
sure pop okay
meaning
no it's just smooth smooth so I'm going
in boom
here
okay right hey this one's not like
you're thinking now so H as I come in I
move off the line you see and I I create
that stal made
but it's the same ground Vector push he
tries to push down he's not going to do
it push it's not going to do it push
it's not going to do it so that's when I
go and I create that sailmate and I grab
that and I'm going to now ground the
front foot okay and I just
pull so you you have to create stale
made got it here we
go hold it up grab
boom
again just so you can see what I'm here
like this it's
[Music]
this got it so it's very gentle right
now but you can see this the same
projection it's just a pulling
projection
okay pull race it's not going anywhere
push we're not going anywhere and I gra
and P throw that that way I leave this
in
space
all
right